Amnesia: The Dark Descent
Here we are.
Back at it again!
Amnesia.
I have not seen this menu in so long and it's so nostalgic.
It's a wonderful menu.
Uh, I thought instead of just doing the new game, we'll do an old custom story.
This one is called "Sealed".
"You are sealed, stuck in your house."
"You cannot get out, nor can you escape your nightmares. Prepare to get scared."
Well, we'll see about that.
I wonder if this is still scary.
I wonder.
"What is that... Noise?"
"Sounds like bugs or... Something else."
"I better get my lantern-"
Okay.
Book!
Fantastic, I love this.
*Mr. Chair* Hey Pewdie! It's me, Mr. Chair!
The game had a wonderful engine. I gotta say that it's so fun to just mess around with.
Alright, where is this...
God damn lantern?
For real though, where is it?
I feel like I've solved every single puzzle you could-
No, I'm not gonna go there.
Alright, this lock..
Where's the fucking lantern?
Chair?
Check if it's safe.
Okay, it's-
God damn, it's dark.
I forgot how dark the game is.
They really did a great job on the..
The light system.
You don't see it in a lot of games.
'Cause you can't see very far.
There she is.
What's happening-
There we go. You have the lantern.
Your best friend.
You use those.
Man, I miss this game.
It was such-
I don't trust you.
All the Pewdiepie memes are coming out.
20-
2012 memes.
Ha!
Alright, I need a key to get past here, apparently.
My God...
Woaaahhh!
Okay, okay, okay. Alright.
I trust you now.
Oh shit, sorry.
What do [did] I do wrong?
What did I do wrong? I'll put you here.
Just to make sure you're safe.
You're too fat.
I know you can get oil from these as well.
There you go.
Okay, now we can go.
And perhaps now we can-
Fuck!
I should try slee-
What?
This is an amazing custom story.
"You're in 'Nightmare Mode',"
"It means you're sleeping, but beware, you can still die."
Oh look, a giant corridor.
I wonder if anything is going to get...
Thrown into my face, perhaps.
Let's check it out.
You can lean in this game as well.
Wooooh!
Oh man, the memories!
Nev-
Oh shit, my man!
Oh shit! Aaah!
Fuck! It's still scary!
It's the fucking sounds, man. The sound is incredible.
Oh shit. Ahh!
Let me go!
We're fine.
Ohh shit!
Down we go.
Woo!
Man, it's still scary, what the fuck?
"Damn it! This is the 27th night.."
27 is very specific.
"..That I didn't get any sleep at all. If this continues, I'll turn insane."
I need the Biblia.
Is that- Biblia!
So much respect for chairs in this game.
Alright, you're coming with me, Mr. Chair.
If that's even your real name!
Suspicious carpet..
I know there's a key under one of the carpets in the game.
Man, should I just replay the original Amnesia?
I didn't wanna do it 'cause it takes so long.
It builds up for like 40 minutes.
Maybe I'll just do that.
All right, what is this custom story, man?
Can I go here?
It's locked!
Ow.
♫ Memories. ♫
There she is.
Eastern. Is that here?
Oh, you have to like..
No?
Very classic uh..
Love the menu.
So simple. It's brilliant!
This game really is brilliant.
There she is.
Very suspicious.
Oh, fuck!
What?
I remember, this is one of the things about Amnesia that was so different.
You couldn't really die.
You d-- Stephano!
hahahaha
*continues laughing*
YES!
So for those of you don't know this guy was like my main guy-
Hey Pewdie, it's been a long time
*laughing*
This fucking statue
And then developers like doing the custom ones they would put it everywhere in the game as a little easter egg
Stefano!
I didn't know he was in this one. That's hilarious.
Where have you been, Poodiepie? It's been 84 years
There you go
Don't worry, bro. Ah, fuck nevermind
It was me that killed you, you son of a bitch!
God damn it. I've been tricked. Oh, God, jump. I'm fine, actually.
Oh, it's my sanity that is low.
I fucking hate 2017 Pewdiepie
Its the worst Pewdiepie, you changed man!
There we go...oh nice, nice head stand there, buddy.
You really got it going for you
I've been stuck in this game, this shitty game...
I don't know if I should do this whole Laudanananaum (trying to say "Laudanum")
Lah-Laudanum
Lau-Laudanum. It's not that hard to say, Felix.
Wow, you really grown a lot, Felix.
Ah, fuck!
There we go, let's take the sanity potion.
[So I ] won't keep fucking collapsing.
What's happened?
Game is loading again.
Oh God. We are in nightmare mode again
Stephano?
Where did you go?
I loved you...
Oh, God
Box
Incredible
*excited gasp*
Barrels!
My good, old friends.
How are you? It's been a long time.
I love you so much
My favorite- barrels are the best, remember?
Its funny, 'cause like...
The game just happened to have a physics system...
where you can interact with objects, cause the game really doesn't have much else
But that just somehow made it so fucking popular for YouTube videos
Where'd he go? You're coming with me, Mr. Barrel.
Very...
weiredly placed carpet.
I feel like that's like...
Let's have a look here; what'd I miss, huh?
Maybe a...
Maybe a key in one of these? NOPE!
Slerrab - okay, I've hidden the key...
...in this room...
under one of the
BARREL
THOSE
FUCKING
BARRELS.
Was it you?
WAS IT YOU?
What?
Oh there!
Aww, HELL no
Aww, HELL no!
Aww HELL no, man.
Imma chill in here, man.
OH Jesus, Remember?
Having to hide from "The bro."
That's actually where "bro" came from, 'cause I -
Oh shit
I kept calling HIM "bro"
EY, BRO!
You got a great ass, bro!
I hope you bros aren't...
---SISTERS. I'm sorry
Looking at this like "Aw man..."
"...look at him now..."
"...He's not even scared or all this shit."
I want this to be sorta... reminiscent.
I'm just gonna go for it.
Nothing.
Oh shit, he broke the door
Well, he didn't see me somehow so that worked out
bYE ByE~~!
Wait, Mr. Barrel.
Of course!
How could you forget about me?
My favorite character of all time, Mr. Barrel
Go!
Ohhh!
HELL NOOO!
Oh HELL NOO!
Oh yeah you feel--
AAaaaAgGGGgHHH!!!
WhAt?!
AGHH!
OHH!
Fuck!
It's still REALLY scary
'cause the sound is fucking awesome
I've never realized that before - I thought..
I thought it was the... the monsters
but I guess the combination of each but, DAMN.
We got some OIL
Being chased... it's still scary as fuck
Eastern Hall Attic Key (Your British is showing, Pewds)
Anyone entering this house must remain for
a great evil lies in wait to devour anyone into its dark cruel grip of a thousand nightmare of hauntings
I remember another thing with a... all the custom mods is that
That really bothered me a lot, it was Uhhh--
and I didn't really acknowledge it at the time, but...
I feel like now I can say it
Just 'cause you can make a good mod, doesn't mean you can write, Ok?
Just 'cause you're a game developer
Doesn't mean you're a fucking writer
Jesus Christ people would put like ESSAYS in the goddamn notes,
and they were SO BAD!
So BADLY written.
My God...
I'm not saying I could do better but Jesus Christ,
it was like-- and people got so pissed.
"You're not reading the notes!"
And I'm like
Ugh, but its SO BAD.
Why would you put all these doors in here, if they're all locked?
Oh!
Oh this is where I--We came from.
What'd I miss, then?
It is sort of charming, though. To revisit.
I like it.
Ah--Is seriously every single door locked?
It brings you to the third point of this game which is...
The Puzzles!
They did a really good job in the original game of balancing...
...you know, the intense moments with...
...puzzles that were really fun and... and still...
...IMMERSIVE to explore.
But I found a lot [of the time] in custom stories...
Ah we still have a key, okay.
I don't know which door it goes to
Uhh...
Y-you get stuck in the custom story,
and we just get kind of annoyed and pissed off, and it breaks the immersion, sorta.
Alright, here we go, this does not look suspicious at all, does it?
Maybe I should replay the original game
Would you guys be down for that FULL Let's Play?
I dunno if that's interesting
BRAP!
Maybe I'll do it for live-stream.
Maybe I'll do it for that
And then you guys can join along
Another
BARREL!!!
Something satisfying ab[out]--
"Why do you hate us, pewds?"
"Is it because we're brown?"
"We know you're a racist now, Pewds."
It's what the media [says]--
OH fuck
Whoah
Maybe I should ask you guys to make a custom story for next like uh
Reddit
Submission thing
Awww Geez...
OH, NO!! (D:)
Oh not the water monster.
The fucking water monster.
OW!
FUCK!!
Ohhh My God, I have a BONE SAW.
...why?
How am I supposed to make it all the way, dude?
That doesn't even help!
I'm just gonna run for it
oooOHHH
MY
GAAAWWWWDDD!
woooooooaaaaAAOOW.
Nailed it!
AHH...
AHH
AH!
FUCK!
FUKFUKFUKFUK
FUuUCK!
ah
ohh
fuck.
AhHAHAHA
ahhh....
It still gets you going, huh, doesn't it?
I'm screaming way too much for this microphone. I'm sorry
WHOO!
Get's your blood going...
Get's your blood going.
*iconic Pewdpiepie laugh*
ohh, Man.
The memories.
The good times.
We had so much fun in this game, man.
SO much fun.
Ohh, man.
The memories!
They're all coming back to me!
They're all coming back--
It's such a shame!
Such a damn shame.
I mean, I fully understand...
The developers of not wanting to do this...
The same game over and over--
They want to make a game they wanna make.
And they made a really great game, I just never got around to play-- What was it called...uh.
Don't remember what it was called, man.
I see the hole there behind uhh...
Nope? Okay, never mind.
I know there was like a
Bone saw. I don't-- Why do I keep picking up bone saws?
There was always hidden stuff THERE...
I know all the hidden spots!
I fuckin...
...played it SO much
Wait, isn't this where we came from?
K, well there's blood in there now.
That's always a great indicator...
of where to go.
This...
This doesn't look bad at all!
"What? I haven't seen this room before!"
"Ohh, Pewds..."
OH, GOD.
That was it! That was it!
ah HAhaHA!
"Adden Holfman"
"odn314"
That was the thing they would add at the-- each ending.
They had a different message, I believe.
At the very end... depending on which ending,
'Cause the game had three different endings, I believe.
Alright, well that-- wasn't that fun to revisit?
Let me know what you guys think
I think that's sort of fits.
Uhhhm.
That sorta fits.
What it was...
for what it was.
Uhh
Thank you guys for watching. I hope you had fun that revisiting this
Uhh, with me. I had a lot of fun.
I'm smiling. I can't stop smiling. It's so fun.
Uhh, Leave a like if you enjoy watching, I'll see you sisters... or BROS!
*whispers* Brofist.
Pewds, we are so glad you had fun! Thank you for making wonderful videos!
- Your subscibers.